[Music]
hello and welcome to crosstalk where all
things are considered I'm Peter lavell
finally the midterm elections and there
are many questions with these races a
referendum on Donald Trump's time in
office
what will the Democrats do in power and
what are Trump's chances in 2020
[Music]
Krauss the midterm elections I'm
joined by my guest mark sloboda here in
Moscow he's an international affairs and
security analysts and we're joined by
Lionel in New York he's a legal analyst
in a news decoder at Lionel media.com
in Chattanooga we cross to Brian Joyce
he's the host of the Brian Joyce show
and in Los Angeles we have ron
own he is a comedian a frequent guest on
the jimmy dore show and the young turks
as well as host of his own streaming
show get your news on with Ron all right
let's start let me start with you mark
here I guess the first thing that comes
to my mind is that there was no blue
wave I Jake Tapper at the CNN evidently
for the first time maybe in history
agrees with you and that was what the
words out of his mouth
early this morning late in in the
evening when aswer yeah so the results
have gone down pretty much as expected
the Republicans retain control of the
Senate the Democrats have recovered the
house and the governor's races are
perhaps a little more split than they
were expected to be so what we saw was
pretty much a standard midterm election
where we see you know the presidential
it's expected that the president's side
will do poorly in midterm elections it's
it's pretty much but we see here split
houses where the Republicans actually
did slightly better in the Senate and
it's it's not been since 1984 that this
has happened
well it's interesting I go to Ron in Los
Angeles what Ron is some kind of
normality return to American politics I
mean the what has the results that we
know now is pretty much conforms with
what we would have expected during a
president's first midterm elections Ron
in LA yeah I kind of echo that too that
this isn't terribly surprising you know
I like a good wave analogy living in
Southern California people are saying
there's gonna be a huge blue wave and I
was like look I think there's gonna be a
kind of ripple but it's not going to be
something you're gonna want to take into
Shore
and I kind of feel like that's
essentially what happened yeah there was
a little little wave there for the house
but then it kind of rippled out in the
Senate and it didn't quite make it to
shore so yeah this is typically what you
see in a midterm with whatever Party is
against what's in the white house those
are the types of gains you see so you
know there are some things on the micro
levels to be optimistic about on the
progressive side of the coin there were
some pickups by DSA back candidates and
stuff like that
meanwhile more establishment back
candidates kind of went down so I think
that's remnant of the trend we're seeing
in our country but yeah as far as
overall results as of right now as of
the recording of this nothing really
atypical you know Brian is the
Republican Party finally now the Trump's
party over this election I mean you know
you can the Republicans can pat
themselves on the back Fox certainly is
doing it but Trump went to red meat
states okay
here's his big tour he was speaking to
the converted already okay but is the
party Trump's party now well I don't
think there's any doubt that the
republican party of 2018 is Donald
Trump's party even here in Tennessee
we've seen we've seen Republicans like a
bob Corker who just they stepped down
bob Corker stepped down because he just
I I'm convinced bob Corker just doesn't
really see a position for himself in the
future of the Republican Party and I
think we've seen that in certain other
cases as well there was some chatter at
first that maybe a guy like Bill Haslam
who was our Republican Governor of
Tennessee very popular would step in and
run for bob Corker seat but bill Haslam
is also a very centrist Republican much
like bob Corker and he didn't even want
to run for that seat because he really
didn't see a path to victory for himself
so I think this is absolutely Donald
Trump's party the victory for Marsha
Blackburn here in Tennessee is
indicative of that right the candidates
who are winning our candidate and so by
and large Oh
Kalyn it's let's go it's got a Lionel
here we have small problem there okay
Lionel with the house going back into
the hands of the Democrats we heard all
through the
the campaign the base is interested in
these investigations investigating Trump
his family Russia gave an interesting
layup was hardly mentioned during this
election cycle amazingly so but you know
we if Pelosi comes back in power as
Speaker what what's the tension going to
be with the base and the centrist and
the Democratic Party when it comes to
Trump dealing with Trump specifically
and I'm using the word the I word
impeachment okay well first and foremost
the greatest thing that could ever
happen and I know this is a big problem
for a lot of my friends is sometimes you
look at this Elvis as a purgative you
know Trump was winning everything one
time he said are you tired of winning
not really and I think what people are
gonna look at this as especially in the
world of stocks as you know Peter
they'll call this a correction right and
every now I know and then during a
correction you're gonna see what the
Democrats have been wanting to do now
what I hope for and I want you to
understand I am a political atheist
I'm leave me I I this president I love
what he's doing by the way what you did
have noticed something Barack Obama and
a couple of instances tried to campaign
with him recently after two days he was
hoarse and exhausted Trump 72 years old
it's a hundred pounds overweight and
he's like the ever-ready battery he was
one of the greatest campaigners of all
time but I hope what happens is that
they let Nancy Pelosi go Full Tilt
boogie and Maxine Waters in charge of
the Senate Finance Committee and I want
Jerry Nadler to be a charge of the the
House Judiciary and I want these people
to go nuts and by the way as you said
where is the reap where is the Russian
interaction here did they drop the ball
does this does this bode ill for
Muller's investigation I just asked
about 20 questions which is why I'm pay
the big bucks to do so so that's your
you've really created the the worst
better the better scenario from your
point of view here mark
you know why don't they bring up a good
point I mean in in macro sense you know
the economy is humming along I think if
you go micro it's a lot more calm
located than a lot of the media likes to
say you know that should have been
something and that should give and Trump
a little bit more oomph because the
economy is doing basically much better
ok again I think it's much more nuanced
by the standards that journalists report
the economy doing well the stock market
the GDP doesn't necessarily reflect how
it's the economy is doing down at the
end of the lines and the pocketbook of
the you know the average family in
different parts of the country but yeah
if the midterm has one punchline it's
not a blue wave it's not the economy
stupid right because obviously Trump was
on the minds we see some two-thirds of
voters had we're voting primarily
because of a strong opinion on Trump
youth women and minorities predictably
turned out very high higher than normal
for the Dems that's a very good point on
that you know the nomaka Los Angeles I
think that's an interesting sign you the
turnout it was higher than expected here
BK and I guess we could that's accounted
for because of the polarization but we
go it and going into the midterms there
are two issues I think that the the
media puts a lot of focus on and with
different angles obviously Kavanagh and
the caravan how did that how do those
two issues play in this election well I
think actually people are hungry for
some real policy ideas I mean I mean you
guys bring up Nancy Pelosi she has said
that her first priority is Trump's tax
returns and pay-go
and people just aren't interested in
that people just aren't interested at
all nor are people interested in these
kind of hot-button issues that the media
just kind of shoves down people's
throats I think people are interested in
real solution real policy ideas that's
why when you look at some of the people
that kind of came close a beta or orc
and Andrew Gilliam you know they both
came out of the gate swinging really
hard and they were kind of steadfast in
their positions then they kind of eased
up a little bit on the medicare-for-all
and Gilliam in particular
to campaigning with Debbie
wasserman-schultz with Hillary Clinton
well then look what happened they kind
of didn't have enough to get to the
finish line so I think people are hungry
for real policy and answers and that's
why that turnout was what it was yeah
you know that's why I love having you on
the program run because you're you're on
the progressive side I'm on the
conservative side but we have one thing
in common we like policy where policy
wonks and they think that's where we
need to get back to Brian let me go back
to you and we want to end the wars we
want to no way to do we're gonna do that
in the next part of the program we're
gonna mention that Brian given what
Lionel has said is in and what Mark just
said here going into 2020 could we see a
red undertow instead of any kind of
waves because if you're gonna go after
attack Trump's taxes and these
investigations and the in light of what
Ron just said there that's not policy
that's just politicking the politics of
personal destruction go ahead Brian well
I mean I'm at the point now where I
think it's next to impossible to predict
what exactly is going to happen you know
I mean if Democrats in the house want to
go after Trump's taxes I don't think
that's a political witch-hunt
necessarily I think there's a lot that
needs to be seen in those tax returns
and I think it would show a lot about
what the president's financial ties are
and and why perhaps he's beholden to
certain foreign interests and that that
is a huge concern of mine I'll be
completely I have to do with policy then
you would count me in okay that is fun
Lionel in one minute before we go to the
break I can tell you what a jump in go
ahead what we are having right now this
wonderfully intelligent roundtable
discussion occurred nowhere among
anybody that I knew this was not an
election about policy or issues or
platforms or dreams this was a a
Rorschach hate fest yeah about Trump
endured there was no logic we're giving
so much intellectual heft we're giving
people around the world the idea that
Americans speak like this no it's the
opposite it was our side versus the
other side and it was based upon a
fundamental
it's a phrenic Trump derangement
syndrome which was the sole basis and
focus of much of the Democratic platform
I'm sorry to break anybody's a bubble
here but to give it the idea that
somehow Americans talk about policy are
you kidding me it was a hey I gotta jump
in here guys we gotta go to a hard break
here after that short break we'll
continue our discussion on the midterm
stay with RT welcome back to crosstalk
where all things are considered on Peter
Lavelle to remind you were discussing
the midterms
[Music]
okay mark let me go back to you here
after everything is said and done what's
a Trump's position right now one of the
interesting things he said right before
the voting stations opened he actually
talked about the importance of tone in
politics maybe I'm reading too much into
it
what's his standing after the dust
settles yeah not good I I think we can
take it this lesson we call it three G's
gerrymandering plus geographical
polarization equals gridlock and that's
what we're looking at going forward and
if you think the Mueller investigation
was bad hold on to your seats because
there's about to be a new bloodsport in
DC these are the things you want to look
at Democrats controlled the house
particularly with the oversight in the
Ways and Means Committee they're gonna
launch subpoenas investigations into
Trump's accusations of sexual harassment
and misconduct into his taxes into
giving Kushner a security clearance
we're gonna see hearings Trump's
legislative agenda is dead dead in the
water if you ever had one and of course
the inevitability of impeachment will
come up on the other side try it with it
with the Senate I mean I mean really I
don't see that happen unless they want
to go through an S theater it'll be one
political fee of course they can't
because of the Senate but political
theater and there's always the potential
for something foreign policy-wise to
flip enough neo-cons in the Senate
depending on you know how things go
foreign policy-wise but Trump will still
control executive orders and he'll try
to legislate out of that remember Obama
and Clinton seem governed with eight
hospitals seems that be that's the trend
here judicial judicial appointments will
be appointed by the sentiment and Trump
of course still has control of the
military you know Ron are we just going
to see more intense part is partisan
conflict here because we do have a split
government now
we have a split Congress but our people
haven't people had enough of just Donald
Trump 24/7 I mean is this really what
the Democrat is this gonna really
benefit the Democrats I think they have
Peter I really do and to respond to some
of the other points others were making I
do take Lionel's point that you don't
hear a lot of policy talk especially via
the corporate media just like every
election cycle this one was treated like
a circus too but a lot of people showed
up because they were voting to legalize
pot in their state or they were voting
to end gerrymandering or something like
that people are hungry for real
solutions and to the point Brian was
making I highly doubt that anywhere in
the heartland of this country where you
have people that are working two and
three jobs just to put food on the table
and if you ask them what they're
concerned about they're gonna say I'm
not really concerned about paying for my
kids college I'm not really concerned
about my ability to go to a doctor I'm
really concerned about seeing Trump's
tax returns if I can just see those tax
returns all the other problems will
solve that self themselves I don't think
that's the country that we live in I
think that's just the hyper partisan
media cycle that we hear twenty-four
hours a day and it's not reflexive of
the people that live in the United
States at all and there's a bunch of
academic studies that back that up Brian
will respond to that because I think all
of us here and maybe that's what makes
us anomalous I'm very interested in
policy and if we have a level of
partisanship intensifying then there's
no room for policy it is just the
politics of personal destruction
personally I'm sick and tired of hearing
what Donald Trump has to say every
single day I really don't care I care
about policy go ahead Brian I care about
policy too I don't really see much
getting done again about how a caravan
of refugees is invading the United
States that's not policy that's a myth I
mean this is it's all just mythology to
the point of Trump's taxes Trump taxes
are very very important to see because
it would reveal whether or not this man
has financial ties to certain oligarchs
in certain countries that should be of a
very very high concern to the average
American this stuff speaks volumes about
the kind of policy that this man is
putting down and the fact that he will
not show them to us that alone that
alone is incredibly suspicious there's
nothing to hide there to show them to us
show them to us okay Lionel this Trump's
taxes keep you up at night no taxes
don't show anything anybody who knows
anything about forensic doesn't mean
anything look the bottom line is this
Peter you're a freak
nobody here wants to talk about policy
and the best thing that could ever
happen to Trump is that they actually do
what was said before if the Democrats go
full-throttle against him and do that it
will be the exhibit a of exactly what he
is talking about doing and finally
crushing the deep state and you don't
think marauding caravans coming into our
country is big news and whose moronic
why are you lying that's a lie there's
no more rotting caravans that's a lie
sir you might want to get your optics
checked because believe it or not we are
seeing this and you may see this and you
may be the only person that I know of
who sees in its way but this is a very
coalition
it's a caravan of refugees a thousand
miles away
who are they Marathi not me well you
both bring up a good point here mark is
that immigration is still front and
center interestingly enough when Trump
went down the escalator that's what he
talked about now we're at the 2018
midterms now they're in the rearview
mirror but that issue still is on front
and center yeah an immigration is a very
polarizing issue and we see a lack of
intelligent policy discussion we have
one side that tries to demonize
immigrants and say all immigration is
bad and we shouldn't have anyone on the
other side we have other sides saying we
should forget borders forget
sovereignties forget our security and
invite everyone in the world whoever
reaches our borders into the country and
neither one of these are
are intelligent ways to discuss an issue
and every president for the last few
decades including Obama including Trump
has admitted that our immigration policy
in our this country is broken but no one
has been able to even put forward any
realistic program any realistic policy
platform for correcting it now I I don't
think that it is a real hot button issue
I think it was political theater on both
sides the forces behind arranging this
care event that was political theater
Trump's faithful Patriot reaction that
was political theater when the New York
Times condemned the idea that American
troops should be put on there on our own
border in a cartoon and suggested rather
that our troops should be off you know
killing people in the Middle East that
is well a condemnation of the moral
bankruptcy of the New York Times it's
the point let me go back to you in Los
Angeles weimar brings up a good point
here and if you could pair let's say for
example Fox News and then MSNBC and CNN
juxtapose them you show you the same
pictures but they tell you a different
story and and again III think
immigration is a very important issue in
it it's a very important depending on
where you live to but it really is
driven by the media cycle of what we see
and what we hear and how the debate is
constructed I mean this is really
constructed chaos at times in the
political sphere go ahead Ron yeah it
certainly is and and I favor a common
sense policy for immigration I also
think that I do also favor abolishing
ice I don't think we need those brutal
tactics I do think the caravan was just
mostly scapegoating nonsense so that's
kind of where a man on the issue I think
it's largely used as a scapegoat
we have a NetZero immigration coming
across the border and I think it's just
kind of a polarizing talking point okay
switch gears here I know Lionel
disagrees that's okay
remarkably in my mind very little
foreign policy was discussed in this
cycle here which I think is extremely
important we have tensions rising all
around the world Donald Trump is taking
a very unilateralis view on many issues
here
traditional American allies are
bewildered if not angered at some issues
here why it doesn't it get into the the
midterms I mean isn't it sexy enough or
is it just so bipartisan you don't want
to turn the applecart over because its
foreign policy is so bipartisan is that
for me yes for you yeah I mean in terms
of a midterm election I don't know
really unless we're talking about tides
of war
whether or not foreign policy really
ever factors too much in it usually is
about the economy stupid I mean in this
case you know there are certainly some
some hot-button regions and hot-button
topics that I think we should be talking
about foreign aid countries right now
yeah well there are eight active
conflicts there eight hundred bases in
80 countries we're bombing nine
countries I I think it's important know
that the thing is is that it's not
brought up into the political discussion
so people can debate it I mean we're
going to just go backwards with Ron and
I were saying here with the caravan I
mean it's made for television coverage
okay and that's what's driving the the
discussion here but I think that when
there's an obligation at least I feel an
obligation that we should look at it a
more broad spectrum because foreign
policy does count we finish at Brian
Fargo to Lionel yeah I mean what I was
suggesting is yes obviously there are
military conflicts around the world and
we have a military presence in regions
of the country we are not in full war
really
anywhere none at this point well you're
in something you wouldn't know you
wouldn't know it from the mainstream
media let me go to Lionel Lionel go
ahead this is the exact reason why
nobody knows what the hell's going on
and this is from a gentleman who was I
think far more versa what's going on in
the world that most people and he
doesn't know what's going on for some
reason I don't know what it is when it
comes to the American needs of the media
palette we think that look we're here
and that's over there and when you talk
about Yemen and maybe will talk about
Saudi Arabia if you're gonna put
somebody up in a bone saw maybe that
gets interesting but we have you talk
about an insular country we have this
idea that unless it's a real war where
we fly over and we have embedded
coverage this is emblematic of the
problem this is why nobody talks about
it because for some reason we are
dyslexic when it comes to the notion of
war this is exhibit a - by the way with
all due respect ok I'm gonna jump in
here many thanks my guests in New York
Chattanooga Los Angeles and here in
Moscow this is the end of our broadcast
segment stay with us for the extended
version on our youtube channel see you
next time and remember crosstalk walls
[Music]
okay now for the extended version of our
program we have political potpourri
alright let's go back to Los Angeles Ron
what what haven't we discussed in this
program that you want to talk about in
light of the midterm elections have
descended well I want to mention a quick
aside kind of responding to something
that we were we're getting off on before
the last segment and at first you know
everyone on this panel we don't agree on
everything but I think virtually all of
us can agree that we want to end the
wars and invest that money back home and
that's something that you don't hear the
media talk about you know they don't
talk about Yemen they don't talk about
all the military budgets that get
approved by partisan by the way approved
by Republicans and Democrats and nobody
talks about it you never hear about it
it just kind of goes down behind closed
doors and I think people are sick of it
and that's something that people all
across the political aisle are kind of
in agreement on also another thing is
you know this is an election election
night as of the recording of this and
the things I was most excited about to
get out of bed for today to go vote here
in California which we don't have the
results of as of now but you know we're
voting for a public bank in Los Angeles
we're voting for the ability to put rent
control on the ballot via prop 10 I
think that the real change we need in
this country is not going to happen just
on the ballot it's gonna happen through
grassroots movements and efforts to get
stuff on the ballot it's gonna happen
via a rise in labor it's gonna happen
via unification and labor and it's gonna
happen via massive strikes so that's
what kind of keeps me optimistic well
that's and that's what make but that's
really the makings of politics politics
really is all local and I think the the
mainstream media misses that there Brian
what's what's the most important thing
that we haven't talked about on this
program in regards to the midterms go
ahead I think one thing that I'm
particularly concerned about is Donald
Trump's ongoing attacks against the Free
Press and against the media I think it's
cute that Donald Trump does not
appreciate all the coverage that he gets
his continued
acts against a free press I would remind
everybody in the world and I would
remind all of my fellow Americans that
the freedom of the press is enshrined in
the Constitution it's right up there
with your right to bear arms and your
freedoms of speech and your freedom of
religion and to see a President of the
United States routinely attacked that
and do it in a very arbitrary right way
he is not the arbiter of what is real
and fake news and in fact he's the
biggest purveyor of fake news in the
entire world so for him to launch that
kind of criticism against the media to
encourage violence against the media it
is not a very healthy place to be I
think it's shameful I think it needs to
be addressed but I'm not gonna hold my
breath
okay well Bryan this thing with you do
you think Google and Facebook have read
the Constitution of the United States it
seems to me that they're playing a major
role in stifling speech I worry about
big tech not Donald Trump in that regard
well Google and Facebook and social
media they do not need to abide by the
Constitution
okay well considering that they could
control the media sphere I think it's a
bit it's very dangerous when we have
these companies determining what free
speech is here Lionel you always have
something to say go ahead
well presidents have been decrying the
media since John Tyler but that's really
not what I think is the most important I
loathe the mainstream media I detest
them I abhor them I I want to see them
crushed and not not via the president
but by attrition I want them to be
concretize and what I want everybody
especially internationally to understand
is that we have a 24/7 I'm sure
everybody else does too but a news cycle
of twenty-year-old per diem basically
fill in the blank
just just human fodder to crank out this
meat grinder 24/7 and they will say
anything no matter what just to say it
and if you listen to everything that has
been said constantly Donald Trump is the
greatest thing that ever happened to
these people in particular this Ted
Baxter
sock puppet pathetic echo chamber horrid
apparatchik repeater
and not reporter world and I have been I
mean it's been bad but when you see
people who for some reason are
considered an expert by some line
producer or somebody with a rolodex from
15 years ago it says look just say
something but I clean up at night just
say something we have been hearing
things it has been absolute diarrhea
drivel and I people just have to see
this what you talk about when you just
said Peter you know I'm a I'm in the
policy I almost one of the policy you
would last 30 seconds on CNN wouldn't
have me okay I would talk about
something meaningful okay go ahead so
the text of this the subtext is I mean
yes this is going on in Trump people
think especially those are people who
are absolute political Tyros who just
woke up five years ago they they loaded
how big God Oh Trump is the worst are
you kidding me he is nothing compared to
what's been said in the past in terms of
American history but I just want people
to understand that it's a sideshow it's
the circus the media okay I agree with
you mark what's your enough to remember
when there were news reports declaring
that Obama was at war with the media and
the Obama administration actually was
sending New York Times Journal of
pushing for New York Times journalist to
go to jail for not revealing their
sources so I'm old enough to remember a
few earlier attacks on the Free Press
than the the the bloviating rhetoric
that's going on right now but I see very
little difference between the two
administrations in that guard to be
perfectly honest they're both sides I'm
I'm very interested in this the story
that has me talked to the deep state
Democrat
we saw an extremely large number of
former I'm speaking myself as a military
veteran former intelligence national
security and military vets run for the
Democratic Party in this race we saw a
forty-six candidates nominated by the
Democrats in the house in the primaries
thirty of them got through to the
nominations that makes them of the of
the seats that the the DCC that the
Democratic Congressional Campaign
Committee was pursuing in the largest
single occupational group there was more
military intelligence people running for
the Democrats than lawyers than
millionaires you know or any other
professional groups you probably this is
probably the only television program
that you have I'll be very interested to
see how many of them when this you know
tally is done how many of them actually
won and how much that is going to affect
what happens in the house when so many
former people who recently left
intelligence services are now setting
you know legislative policy in one last
question to everyone here very simple
one and I know you're all gonna hate but
hate this question what about 2020 Ron
now we get to start all over again okay
what what how well are they how well are
the Democrats position for 2020 and and
the left go ahead it depends on who the
nominee is I I think that if the
Democrats try to push another centrist
blank suit down America's throats
they're gonna Louie I think well Clinton
you're guaranteed eight years a trump if
Clinton and and III think Biden would
likely lose - so it all depends and as
far as you know I'm trying not to think
about it you know if there's one thing I
really I know it's really really earlier
when we're almost out of hunting Brian
2020 I mean in light of what's happened
in
there the recent midterms what's what's
your what's the position Ron I think it
all depends on who Democrats run it's as
simple as that if they run somebody
who's capable of beating Trump
they'll be Trump if they don't you know
I mean we've seen that Donald Trump can
pretty much bully an election cycle and
a media cycle any which way he likes it
so you're gonna have to put up a
candidate who can roll with that and who
can challenge them
okay Lionel last the last minute goes to
you is there a possibility of a red
undertone in favor of Trump for 2020
well Trump will be the next president
after this guaranteed but also you're
gonna be seeing the Democrats finally
grow up you're gonna see the adult
version of the of the party come forward
and say listen we're gonna get rid of
this this this
oh she owes baggage hillary goodbye if
you're not indicted go maxine go Pelosi
go get rid of the octogenarians new
blood but specifically with an idea and
i hope this is just a hope not a plan
but i hope that one day the democratic
party returns to the democratic party
that i used to love that i came up
respecting okay what we're gonna end on
lionel saying he used to love the
democratic party that's an interesting
way to end the program we've hoped you
enjoyed this extended version and we'll
see you uh maybe in twenty twenty you
doing this exactly the same thing
you